on en voyait autrefois beaucoup des
vaches au pâturage
mais aujourd'hui elles ont presque
complètement disparu du paysage rural de
nombreux producteurs sont d'avis que
c'est plus simple de garder les animaux
à l'intérieur à l'année mais qu'en est
il des principales intéressées sont
elles mieux dans les tables ou au grand
air la science a tranché
où
auparavant les vaches faisait partie du
paysage rural
[Musique]
depuis leur disparition des champs
certains transformateurs laitiers
persiste à nous montrer une image
idyllique de vache qui broutent
lorsqu'ils font la promotion de leurs
produits
mais la réalité c'est qu'au québec
la vaste majorité des vaches fassent
leur vie enfermé dans une étable
moi je me disais un jour ils vont sortir
recueillant parlez pas de prix la rumeur
françois tremblay un producteur laitier
de métabetchouane au lac saint jean a
rompu avec le modèle dominant le
confinement eu des effets sur la
population se voit que dieu j'ai pas
besoin d'être un scientifique pour pour
pour prouver que les vaches on peut on
peut simplement pas d'effet sur les
vaches le confinement ses vaches sont
élevées en stabulation entravée
c'est à dire que dans les tables elles
sont attachées
mais au lieu de les garder enfermés
toute l'année comme il le faisait
auparavant il les envoie maintenant au
pâturage plusieurs heures par jour sept
mois par année ce virage françois
tremblay l'a fait parce que ces vaches
perdre et de la mobilité
juste le fait de déplacer livrée pour
eux souhaitent changer l'ordre de traite
ou l'échangé d'install pour lui donner
une alimentation à préparation 20 large
c'est un stress parce qu'elle y marche
ça va être du marché et puis juste le
fait de deux hôtels dalloul ont amorcé
avec des vaches que dit fouet
il marquait le coup qui tombe à terre
puis on se disait que les maraudes sur
le riz pire leur taux de mortalité
augmenter c'est surtout au niveau des
pieds des mains en bleu que je trouvais
le cas vers une réelle problématique
puis je vais avoir à mon sens avec des
vaches qui était de plus en plus les
marbres et au niveau des pattes ça me
faisait faire de la réforme quand même
précoce sur certaines vaches à lait que
je les envoie à l'abattoir
quand il y avait deux à trois lactation
pilot je trouvais que ça faisait du lait
qui était quand même assez dispendieux
reproduire
une méta analyse parue en 2015 temps à
lui donner raison
l'étude a comparé le taux de mortalité
de deux groupes celles qui vont aux
pâturages et les confiner les vaches
confiné qu'elle soit élevé en
stabulation entravée ou en stabulation
libre
un système qui leur permet de bouger
seulement à l'intérieur d'une étable ont
un taux de mortalité plus élevé que les
vaches qui monte au pâturage
l'autre conclusion des scientifiques
c'est que les vaches qu'on n'en voit
jamais auprès souffrent davantage de
boiterie de lésions jarrets de même heat
et autres problèmes du terrain que
celles qui vont au pâturage
c'est toujours intéressant quand on est
capable d'avoir une étude qui vient
comme là puisque nous on voit sur le
terrain
donc c'est sûr que ça devient un élément
plus finalement pour pour convaincre les
producteurs françois labelle prêche
depuis longtemps en faveur du pâturage
la production de lait biologique dont il
est spécialiste est la seule qui exige
que les vaches broutent de l'herbe
aussi longtemps que la température le
permet
au québec seulement 2,3 pour cent des
producteurs laitiers détiennent cette
certification la ferme au gré des champs
à saint jean sur richelieu en montérégie
est une pionnière en la matière sont les
sert uniquement à fabriquer des fromages
biologiques un producteur biologique
l'après-midi de basse et de verbes et on
veut pouvoir offrir aux vaches un
environnement le plus proche possible de
leur nature
à la base c vhc inclus mineurs c'est
fait pour goûter à l'extérieur pour
interagir ou par tirage pour manger de
l'herbe
donc pour moi c'est un peu contre nature
de les confiner constamment ici
l'espérance de vie des vaches et de cinq
ans alors que la moyenne québécoise est
de 3 ans et 10 mois
marc tallec 14h mandat le 12 heures on a
aussi encore là la firme artec 8
on a beaucoup dit rivage les vaches qui
sont à l'extérieur ils sont très
stimulés par exemple pendant la journée
ils vont être confrontés à d'autres
animaux selon moi en fait ça fait des
années qu'ils sont plus résilient au
stress qui sont habitués des dissimulé
après dans le bâtiment sis arrive
quelque chose ou un changement
d'alimentation
ils sont plus résistantes à ce genre de
changement la puissance à contribuer à
leur santé à long terme et ses vaches on
pourrait croire qu'elle préfère le
confort de les tables surtout
lorsqu'elles sont élevées en stabulation
libre comme ici
mais la méta-analyse qui a comparé les
avantages du pâturage au confinement
prouve le contraire
lorsqu'elles ont le choix les vaches
monte au pâturage 62 % du temps celle de
la ferme au gré des champs ne se font
pas prier pour sortir de mai à octobre
on voit visuellement que les vaches à
temps d'aller d'or et les aime ça c'est
certain que c'est flagrant après l'hiver
et quand on ouvre la barrière pour la
première fois éco sans vraiment que si
c'est le même les plus vieilles est une
des vaches clicquot c'est pas tellement
gracieux fait que c'est toujours un
spectacle d'un drôle c'est vraiment
agréable on s'inquiète des copines
malgré tout le pâturage ne pas toujours
bonne réputation parce qu'auparavant
avec cette méthode les champs finissait
par ressembler à ça votre peau de vache
on ouvrait la porte au printemps puis on
les faisait rentrer à l'automne sans
aucune gestion donc ont donné un grand
champ après plus ou moins un mois la
production d'herbe était paul ohl les
animaux dépérissait la production de les
baisser
on avait du parasitisme parce que les
animaux faisait finalement du
surpâturage puis même même les
rendements au niveau des champs
diminuent et carrément donc on se
retrouvait avec des grandes parcelles
qui était pas productive du tout là
depuis quelques années la technique
s'est améliorée avec le pâturage
intensif en bande
le chant est subdivisé en petites
parcelles où l'on fait passer les vaches
en rotation à l'aide de clôture mobile
la banque est séparée avec des moulinets
de jetons au besoin une fois que l'eau
ça s arrete brouter l homo je choisis
une autre porte plus loin un cocalero
pas plus haute que me posent comme les
envois pâturer l'eau en été
les vaches de françois tremblay mange
75% d'herbe fraîche et 25 portion de
concentré de protéines
donc c'est lord à l'opa sera renouvelée
de tâches pas qu'ils savent qu'ils vont
toujours avoir une bande 9 qui a pas été
piétinées et puis que qui prête à manger
puis qui est fraîche puis moins ce que
j'ai asseyé le prix du lotier salle à
une bonne gestion bilité puis
[Musique]
ils mangent du frais image plus de marge
à conserver l'eau et puisque la vache
récolte elle même le forage en broutant
l'herbe et qu'il est pensons propre
fumier la production de fourrage coûte
50 % de moins par année
malgré cela au québec seulement 13% des
producteurs de lait conventionnel comme
françois tremblay on voit leurs vaches
en lactation au pâturage
c'est que la méthode a aussi des
avantages ou courant de la journée ou
même au courant de la semaine on une
variation niveau 2 du type d'aliment que
les vaches consent depuis une route de
quantité énergie protéines qui vont
consommer en une variation dans le
système actuel on a un coteau
journalières produit on a des quantités
de lait vraiment précise en produira
chaque jour donc des producteurs peuvent
pas se permettre d'avoir un grand décor
entre les journées sans compter qu'avec
le pâturage les rendements sont moins
bons le gros inconvénient ces cellules
c'est la baisse de production qui peut
être allégée peut-être jusqu'à 10 % dans
certains cov moche kg comme argument l
eau peut être que je ferai un petit peu
moins de lait mais je ferai du lait qui
est plus payant c'est à dire que qui ne
coûte pas très cher a concentré et puis
on a beaucoup moins de fourrage à
produire faites-le sidikou de moins en
carburant puis en plastique en ballon
puis tous qui filait
on a besoin de moyens d'infrastructure
moins deux silos sylla le producteur
redone leur sillage pour nous -
d'entreposage pour le foin sec puis
aussi bien l'aspect déterminant sens où
les vaches plus en santé ça coûte moins
cher d'internet au sein l'impact
financier sur une entreprise quoi qu'il
en soit à l'heure où l'on se préoccupe
davantage du bien-être des animaux
d'élevage
le pâturage à la cote
bush convaincu que les consommateurs
sont prêts pour ça parce que de plus en
plus on entend parler de bien-être
animal puis les gens
ce qu'ils veulent c'est que les animaux
soient respectés puis sont prêts à
mettre le prix pour ça mais nous on a
toujours vu cette demande l'eau cette
exigence le des consommateurs comme une
opportunité de s'améliorer se placer
dans une niche de devenir d un peu des
pionniers d'aller au-devant de la vague
ça plaît beaucoup à nos clients un
convoi aussi aussi comme un outil des
banques et émis depuis du style c'est on
se le cache pas ça fait partie de notre
stratégie d'affaires
un transformateur québécois a lui aussi
fleuri l'occasion il vient tout juste
d'ajouter l'appellation vaches au
pâturage sur certains de ces litres de
lait le lait biologique est
nécessairement issus de vaches au
pâturage
mais on ne faisait pas la promotion de
cette particularité
jusqu'à tout récemment quant à sa
mention vaches en liberté qui vient elle
aussi d'apparaître sur certains litres
de lait elle porte à confusion
elle signifie simplement que les vaches
sont élevées en stabulation libre sans
garantie d'accès aux pâturages
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
les sorties au pâturage ne sont pas
réservées seulement au petit troupeau en
fait la taille n'est pas vraiment un
facteur limitant
à preuve dimanche trop pour de plusieurs
centaines et milliers de vaches en
nouvelle-zélande et en europe vont pas
être dans les prés et autre fait
intéressant
en suède on a même inscrit l'accès aux
pâturages dans les lois là bas les
vaches doivent obligatoirement passer
huit heures par jour dehors un certain
nombre de mois par année